what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so continuing on with our
discussion on the Marvel cosmic
landscape at this point we pick up with
two things really like the death of
Thanos and the origin of Drax the
destroyer now it's also kind of cool cuz
we're gonna pick up with moon dragon
here as well and this will really be
like the first time we've talked about
Heather Douglas we never really had a
reason to discuss her before but the
fact remains that the last video that we
had on this we basically had like the
controller who is basically a guy that
was essentially creating these little
disks that were taking control of
people's minds he wasn't really relevant
we ended up finding out that he was
basically just a henchman of Thanos
and that there were certain people fan
OHS was basically controlling a keep in
mind this was back in the day when
Thanos was still relatively new to the
Marvel landscape so in a lot of ways jim
Starlin was still flushing his character
out now in this day and age right now
because Thanos is so powerful you would
never see him go to someone like the
controller insect make mind-control
discs for me so I can conquer earth or I
can infiltrate earth instead he would
just show up and just start wrecking
people but a lot was because of the
stuff that was done here because of this
jim Starlin type of type of storytelling
for back in the 1970s and so what we end
up doing here is basically picking up
with Thanos in possession of the cosmic
key which is what we had in the last
video in the last video with his
character we essentially ended with
Thanos himself acquiring the Cosmic Cube
after having defeated Drax the destroyer
now the cool thing about this is
remember the Cosmic Cube is not new here
it's not the first time it's ever
appeared in Marvel Comics it's been
around for a while but when jim Starlin
was going through and this is one of the
things that writers still do to this day
especially people like Hickman things
like that when Jim stone was writing
this story it was really a matter of
kind of going through and looking what
had been done so far and when we looked
at the Cosmic Cube
by and large the Cosmic Cube was used
exactly as Thanos describes it for petty
ambitions for small time things you know
you never saw an advanced idea mechanics
or the Red Skull gain a Cosmic Cube and
then say I'm gonna conquer the universe
instead they just saw them as really
powerful artifacts but what they didn't
know was the true nature of a cosmic
cube and that's what Thanos Hits had
here Thanos basically says this cosmic
cube is a wishing box now a couple
things that we're gonna do here at least
one thing that I want to do is I want to
I want to kind of grab some current some
modern date information and throw it in
there at the time that this was done the
cosmic cubes were never fully fleshed
out the cosmic he wasn't really fleshed
out until fantastic for like 214 or
something along those lines which was
the unofficial Secret Wars 3 when it
came to the cosmic cubes originally they
were exactly as you see it just a box
that can
a lot of energy and you would basically
have a portal that would be open and the
energy would come from that portal and
it would enter into a stasis cube of
sorts and then a person could use that
energy for virtually anything they
wanted to now this is one of those times
when Stirling comes along and says the
energy of a cosmic heat is not infinite
and so in this instance that's a concept
that he's toying with but with regards
to the nature of the cubes themselves
what we learned really and within the
last maybe 20 years I'm in 20 years I'd
say probably last 30 years that Marvel
Comics has been publishing what we ended
up learning is that a cosmic cube when a
person goes to create one what they do
is they open a pocket dimension to the
realm of the beyonders or I guess a
portal to the realm of the beyonders
just these beings of astronomical power
I mean we saw that in secret Wars when
they basically killed all the cosmic
entities except the one above all they
kill the living tribe you know in you
know infinity eternity they destroyed
the multiverse the whole nine yards that
energy from a cosmic cube goes directly
into the you know containment cube which
is you know the cosmic cube itself and
then a person can use it the truth is
that they are immensely powerful meaning
you can do anything you want with the
Cosmic Cube
you can even defy the laws of physics so
it's really crazy the kind of things
that you can pull off but again at this
point we jump into the character of moon
dragon now with a Heather Douglas she is
extremely powerful when it comes to
telepathy that's really the only thing
she does have him if she does have a
fighting ability but whatever you see
moon dragon you're only ever really
going to see her using telepathy I mean
you might see her do a few things here
and there but with Heather it's really
just telepathy that's really all she has
and so what we end up finding out is
that Drax the destroyer after having
been defeated by Thanos effectively came
to and then showed up at Avengers
mansion but for most of these people
they've never heard of this guy they
don't know who he is they just know him
yeah or at least they don't know him as
Drax a destroyer he's just a guy who's
there and so because of the fact that
Captain Marvel has met drops because of
the fact that Captain Marvel knows who
he is what he ends up doing is stopping
the entire conflict but the fact remains
here then what we end up finding out at
least is one reasons why this is so
significant is because this begins to
hit at the relationship between fan OHS
and mistress deaths so for those of you
guys who are familiar with Thanos but
you've been curious how it is that
Thanos and mistress death first got
together this is really it now in terms
of Marvel's publication chronology this
is the first time we ever see the two of
them together in terms of the end
universe continuity the end universe
chronology this is not the first time
we've seen them together if you go back
and you read the book
rising by Ed Brubaker I want to say it
is it hits back at the origin of Thanos
and what it says is that when he was a
little kid he was met by mistress death
for the very first time now we're not
given an explicit reason as to why at
least I'm not particularly told as to
why and even not at Brewbaker kind of
hits on the idea says well maybe it's
because he's basically a mutant among
his own people maybe it's because you
know there was a kind of darkness hidden
within him but for whatever reason
mistress death had an interest in Thanos
and the result is that she cultivated
this darker side of his character so
that as he began to rise into his
adolescent years going into his teenage
years his 20s is thirty so on and so
forth he became obsessed with death and
as a result he eventually rose to become
the person that we know now now with
analyst raj and there were a lot of
things going on behind the scenes in
terms of his character the various
escapades that he was in but the long
and short of it was that over the course
of that story he developed a love for
mistress death and that's why this is
the case he's effectively in love with
her and that's all he ever really
desires to do is to impress her now
again this is the first time we really
see a demonstration of the fact that
Thanos is in love with mistress death
that he absolutely loves her in terms of
the publication history so this is a
very significant moment in the realm of
Marvel Comics with regards to the
character of Thanos and so on but
because of the fact that Thanos is
wielding the Cosmic Cube what he does is
he kind of sits down and he says okay so
there are a handful of people that are
more important than others you know for
example Marvel mentor the father of
Thanos eros the brother of Panos
basically anyone who's ever fought
Thanos or is aware of him or what he's
capable of is immediately removed now
it's not done in the same vein as like
the Infinity Gauntlet right it sound
like he walks out and then just snaps
his fingers and blinks out half a life
in the universe instead what he does is
he puts them in a kind of bioelectric
field and simply forces them to watch
now this is important because those are
the guys who are familiar with the
Infinity Gauntlet story that'll be
history repeating itself it won't be the
first time that one Thanos has gathered
the Infinity stones he's done that
before but - it's not the first time he
allowed his arrogance to run away with
him that was the whole basis of the
Infinity Gauntlet story Thanos became
just exceedingly arrogant and as a
result it essentially cost him
everything again we've got all that
stuff covered but the fact remains that
most basically forces these guys to
watch when he sends in his rating Hardy
as rating fleet or whatever it is and
they just attack earth again this is
early stuff that's something to keep in
mind because of the fact that jim
Starlin was basically writing stories
that were reminiscent of superhero
in supervillain escapades at the time
Thanos despite being as powerful as he
is at the end of the day was basically
written like your run-of-the-mill
villain that he's got his own henchman
he's implementing his own schemes that's
really about it it wouldn't be until
after this when Thanos began to really
rise in popularity among readers that
jim Starlin would start going in the
direction of making Thanos like a
one-man band that basically would just
be him and his schemes misters death
might be around there somewhere but
basically Thanos can take on anything in
the universe given enough time and
probably wins so that's that's where all
that stuff really begins to come in but
this really begins to hit home because
Thanos having the the Cosmic Cube really
like taunts people you know for example
like mentor and various people to speak
up do you really believe you stand a
chance you know we're just normal people
but what chance do you stand against
gods and that's when he brings in
Chronos who's basically the God of the
Titans the race of a fan of himself and
Suzy says I've captured a cosmic entity
this cosmic entity is now under my
control but notice this is limited this
is limited in a lot of ways now the
reason why we don't we don't really see
things like eternity the reason why we
don't really see things like Galactus
here is because this was experimentation
this was testing the waters when it came
to a story like Infinity Gauntlet a lot
of people look at that and say that's
when Thanos peaked that was the most
powerful he'd ever been and so if we
were to grab the you know series of
stories where they actually took place
in the Marvel Universe and had
consequences in the future of the Marvel
Universe something that's referenced
continually that Infinity Gauntlet is
probably the most significant moment in
Thanos his history and so the result is
that it was really kind of building up
to that now if this had happened here
let's say for example Pharaohs for the
Cosmic Cube and he defeated all the
cosmic entities and we basically got
everything that happened in Infinity
Gauntlet in this story danos would have
peaked in the mid-1970s and he would
have dropped off after that and so it
was just a matter of experimentation it
was a matter of testing the waters how
will people respond to a being of
universal intelligence and almost
incalculable power amplifying all that
by acquiring a cosmic cube and then
intending to just obliterate the
universe you know how does all that work
now the other half of this was to build
on the arrogance of Thanos
for Jim Stalin when he originally
introduced him it was the idea that
Thanos didn't even think the earth
superheroes were worthy of his attention
hence the reason why he didn't show up
himself it was a robot that he had sent
in his place now that was kind of toying
with the idea of our people even
interested miss character in the first
place but that was a nature of a for
example for those of you guys who have
seen the trailer to our infinity
the reason why Thanos shows up without
all of his suit on it's a display of
power is essentially him showing up and
saying look I don't even have to get
decked like I don't have to put on the
armor or anything like that like you're
earthlings how powerful could you really
be and then just shows up and takes the
Infinity stones and least it's walking
into a grocery there's walking into a
corner store grabbing a diet coke paying
and walking there's no real concern
there there's no real worry there it's
just going in doing what you needed to
do and then leaving and that's it what
hope do earth superheroes have that's
the kind of power that's being put on
display when it came to the infinity war
trailer but that's what happens here I
mean with the power of the cosmic heute
here it is kind of traditional
storytelling it's old-school
storytelling and the reason why I say
that is because in order to be able to
craft a story that would work in a way
to where the Earth's superheroes would
still have a chance what we end up
having is basically Captain Marvel
invoking the the bracelets that he wears
so for those who guys who don't know
again the idea of Captain Marvel is that
the the mega bands I think they were uh
he basically hits them together and
switches places with Rick Jones the
person that Bruce Banner rescued and was
hit with a gamma bomb but the idea was
adhere back in the day essentially
Captain Marvel would hit his bands
together and then it would allow him to
switch places with Rick Jones and
Captain Marvel would go into the
negative zone and Rick Jones would be
the one who would walk around and if
they hit them again the roles would
reversed what is happening here is
Marvel hits as bands together and it
quote-unquote short-circuits the
bioelectric field it's kind of cheap
it's kind of you know like all right
this is obviously an out but this is how
comics were done back then it's one of
those things where college had just kind
of evolved over the years so that's why
we get that little bit of a of a cheap
escape here but at this point if Thanos
who's basically in the midst of an
attack with the various Avengers he
loses the Cosmic Cube for a moment and
then that's really about it at that
point it turns into Captain Marvel it's
kind of facing off against him he gets
trashed and then moon dragon uses her
telepathy now for the most part while
her character has progressed over the
years even back then back at the time
this story was written moon Dragon was
established as being one of the most
powerful beings in existence in the
Marvel Universe now as far as I'm aware
moon dragons been dead since like
anihilation conquest she's been gone for
a while
and in fact she was turned into a
literal dragon at one point in time
which is kind of weird but her telepathy
has always been up there she's also also
made like passes at a lot of different
characters which is kind of weird it's
kind of interesting but it is cool but
again this is design a hit home with the
idea that Thanos is incredibly powerful
that it's not just like energy
projection it's not just raw physical
strength it's also the power of the mind
and that's one of the things that
Starla's going to consistently hit on
that's why all these things are really
kind of like the foundation of Thanos's
growth as a character because what this
initial line of stories is supposed to
do basically this cosmic cube saga what
this is designed to do is basically say
okay so there is a villain named Thanos
and he worships death and Thanos is
incredibly strong and Thanos is
incredibly powerful when it comes to
energy and Thanos his mind is almost
unrivaled except by some of the most
intelligent or some of the most mentally
powerful beings out there but when it
comes to that higher echelon you know
like Galactus or like Reed Richards or
somebody like that very few people can
stand you know stand toe-to-toe with the
intellect and the experience of fantasy
but again all these guys were defeated
pretty fast by Thanos who again
reacquires a cosmic cube and sort of
calls it a day and just kind of takes
the cube and then ends up facing off
against rocks a destroyer for a second
and then discards the Cosmic Cube and
that's it he really kind of throws it
away under this idea that the cosmic
cubes energy has been drained and so it
is kind of interesting because what
Thanos does isn't draining the
quote-unquote Cosmic Cube energy
he basically elevates himself to godhood
now again the Cosmic Cube is a is a
wishing box but as far as I'm aware and
I could be wrong about this as far as
I'm aware the energy use of the Cosmic
Cube is not contextual on what a person
does and what I mean by that is I'm not
aware of there being a precedent to
basically say if you wish for a spoon
you only use 1% of the cosmic cubes
energy and if you wish for reality
warping powers you use 75% of the cosmic
cubes energy I'm not aware of that being
the case it may be that is one of those
things were just kind of worked out that
way but again I haven't tracked every
single use in every single storyline
every single instance of the Cosmic Cube
I probably should since that's kind of
what my channel is designed to do but
the fact remains it is kind of
interesting because Jacque showed a
story this really hits of the nature of
Drax he is designed singularly for the
purpose of defeating Thanos that's it
and this is when we hit back at the
nature or really the origin of Drax the
destroyer and it's actually pretty cool
initially this all kind of kicks off
with Thanos using the Cosmic Cube to
basically just kind of create these
demonic looking beings out of just like
machinery and the whole of you know the
bessel they're on and that's really
about it I Captain Marvel faces off
against them you know an Iron Man faces
off against them and you know some of
these things are kind of destroyed and
that's really about it but when
rocks ghost to face off directly against
Thanos it is almost godlike state Thanos
in turn reveals the origin of Drax a
destroyer and this is cool because this
also reveals the origin of Heather
Douglas the daughter of Drax and so what
we end up finding out here is that in
like the mid-1950s Thanos was basically
scouting earth because at this point he
was hunting for the Cosmic Cube he was
trying to find where was that it was
located and earth made sense you know of
all the different beings that were
rising to prominence the kind of power
of the different beings on earth
possessed even back then in the 50s
while it wasn't nearly where it wasn't
like the 60s and 70s even back then
there were still a lot of powerful
beings on earth
and so where Thanos had scouted earth
but intended to remain undetected
he had ultimately had a kind of
calculation error and then he was seen
by by Arthur Douglas and as a result he
basically obliterated their car in the
process of vet Douglas the wife of Drax
the destroyer died and in Heather was
was thought to have been dead and Arthur
himself died and the result was that
Heather had actually survived a crash
and when she did she was effectively
taken by mentor the father of Thanos and
then brought to Titan itself and there
she was trained on how to use her powers
of telepathy as well as becoming you
know exceedingly good at hand-to-hand
combat and so the result was at his time
progressed she began to rise to
prominence and then became the character
of moon dragon for Arthur Douglas
himself when the decision was made by
Chronos the god of the Titans to create
a beam that could single-handedly defeat
Thanos it made sense to create a being
that basically would have a vendetta
against Thanos and the reason why was
because if Drax a destroyer was made
singularly for the purpose of defeating
Thanos but we also know his he was given
autonomy he was given the ability to
operate according to his own wishes and
wants his own desires he wasn't designed
with a preset of programming that he
would always try to always try to
complete as the result is that Chronos
seemed to know that at some point along
the line jaxa destroyer may decide not
to attack that us anymore
maybe he fights him five times and
realized it's a mute point and just says
whatever I'm just gonna go explore the
universe who knows but there needed to
be something else that kicked in a kind
of secondary motivation and so when Drax
the destroyer ears memories were most
likely restored whether it was by his
own volition or because somebody else
returned them it would give him a
continued motivation to track down
Thanos because in essence Thanos killed
the family of Drax the destroyer and
that's exactly what happens here now for
those of you guys from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe that's kind of what's
going on to a degree the MCU has
modified
a bit in the sense that they said that
Ron and the accuser was the one that had
you know destroyed the family of Drax I
wouldn't be surprised if Marvel came
back and they said well Rhonda the
accuser did it but he did it because
Thanos told him to ah that will most
likely be what happens and then I could
see them bringing in the character of
moon dragon and bringing in the origin
the full-on origin of Dracula story
because remember we haven't really seen
the full origin of Drax in the MCU we
don't really know everything that goes
on with this character but the fact
remains here that in the midst of all
this Marvel's basically met with the
arrival of Isaac now remember Isaac is
the computer system that was designed by
mentor on the moon Titan to basically
govern the goings on of the Titan people
it is cool because Isaac is able to
basically look at everything that's
going on and kind of analyze things in a
way that a person normally wouldn't be
able to because because of the fact that
they're tied up with everything that's
going on and then effectively answered
questions for people and so what is up
happening is Marvel asked the question
how can i defeat these demons and Isaac
respond says you can't
the only way for you to defeat them is
to leave this plane of existence
otherwise they will track you forever
they will find you forever either that
or you have to somehow destroy Thanos
which is probably something that you
can't really pull off and so the result
is that Captain Marvel has the idea well
then I'll just turn into Rick Jones like
I literally hit my bands together Rick
Jones will pop out Captain Marvel will
be gone and if these machines are
chasing after the essence of Captain
Marvel then they won't do anything and
that's exactly what happens because of
the fact that Marvel and and Rick Jones
switched places
ultimately we end up having these robots
just kind of stop and that's really
about it now with Rick Jones grabbing
the Cosmic Cube teleports himself away
goes to a quote-unquote safe place but
it is cool because what he does is he
taunts Thanos and this is when the
arrogance and the ego of Thanos begin to
come into play because Rick Jones
basically taunts him and says hey look
if you were really as powerful as you
say you are then you would deal with us
yourself you wouldn't send in thralls
it's basically a young kid talking trash
if this was X Fox Thanos would track
this kid down that's really what this is
it's kind of funny and it's actually
pretty intelligent to kind of prey on
that ego of source to essentially build
on that idea but the whole point of this
was to essentially allow Marvel to get
away from these demons and then bring a
nose to him so that he could focus on
Thanos explicitly in kind of a
one-on-one battle and that's exactly
what happens but we end up having as
Marvel just kind of hits his ban I guess
Rick Jones hits his mans together him
and Marvel switch places again and
Captain Marvel's back in the field now
the other thing to bear in mind here is
a
this is still Thanos exceedingly
powerful he's still using all this
energy so while Marvel is able to fight
to a degree and able to hold his own to
a degree at the end of the day he's not
godly powerful and he's not really able
to defeat Thanos in the traditional
sense it ultimately doesn't work that
way he just doesn't have the capability
to pull it off and so the result is that
you know of course Drax and Marvel kind
of team up to a degree but Marvel comes
to a realization what he says is that
the the energy that they oasiz using has
to be coming from somewhere because of
the way the cosmic cubes work when a
person used the Cosmic Cube to achieve a
goal that energy is continually drawn
from the Cosmic Cube in order to make
sure that goal stays intact and so when
Marvel kind of looks around in the
landscape what he realizes if Stan was
pulled an incredibly intelligent ruse
that when they were all back on the ship
that thanasis said well I'll drain the
energy of the Cosmic Cube and then just
threw it away and no one had any reason
to question it no one had any reason to
wonder if Thanos lying or not is the
cube still full of energy but Marvel
puts two and two together and actually
realizes Danos is still drawing on the
cosmic tubes energy is the only way for
him to maintain his current form the
Cosmic Cube has to be located somewhere
and then ultimately is able to track it
down Marvel manages to find the Cosmic
Cube and then effectively destroy its
physical form and when he does vanos
goes with Thanos his essence is just
kind of dispersed among the space waste
and Thanos essentially dies he doesn't
really have a form anymore and so what
this did is it allowed for jim Starlin
to Connor Tate the character of Thanos
and sort of sit him on the back burner
for a little bit and then at that point
switch over to focusing more on Adam
warlock as some of the things that came
out for that with regards to sort of
evolving his character as a cosmic
figure but the fact remains that at this
point in time this is where Thanos dies
this is basically his first death he's
essentially gone and it's kind of ironic
because they talked about that the idea
to Thanos worship death and Danos now
gets to finally be with death so it is
interesting it is kind of a cool little
thing but again it's one of these things
where the story just kind of wraps up
super fast it's not designed to linger
and sound design is dragging on you get
like a one-page epilogue where
everybody's just kind of like man that
was crazy man I can't believe that
happened but you know I mean all in a
day of the Avengers and they all go back
to the Avengers HQ and that's it
the story of Captain Marvel picks up
with another story and that's that's
really about it but if you guys are new
here to comments explain make sure you
guys at the sub button to become part of
the robb core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and
yeah in the next video we pick up with
the return of Thanos and the events that
led into Infinity Gauntlet well that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end now we'll catch you all
later purse
[Music]